what the hell has happened to giant
robots mecha is one of the most famous
and well respected genres to ever exist
in the medium of anime for a good amount
of time giant robots weren't just
synonymous with anime giant robots were
anime trying to imagine this medium
without giant robots it's almost like
trying to imagine star wars without
lightsabers its lineage is about as old
as anime itself and is full of
prestigious titles that have shaped the
medium as a whole whether you're a mecha
fan or not you have felt the effects of
this genre every decade brought new
classics that have ingrained themselves
in the hearts of the anime fans of their
era and this was no different for me
when I got into anime in the mid 2000s
Code Geass gurren lagaan arica 7 Full
Metal Panic Gundam double-o rasa Fon
these weren't just good mecha shows
these made people into mecha fans these
are up there some of the most iconic
anime of their decade and as with every
previous decade there had always been a
fair few mecha shows that have helped
define that period so going into the
2010s we all as usual waited for the
next big mecha franchise to rise up as
it always had and so we waited and
waited and waited and then everyone in
Japan just became truck drivers the
2010s has been the most barren decade
for mecha in the history of mecca in an
era where we have more anime coming out
than anyone can feasibly keep up with
this year there have been a total of
three new TV mecha shows three there was
less mecha this whole year than half the
number of yokai airing this season and I
can also say that in this whole year
there's only really been one big mecha
show that's been released Neon Genesis
Evangelion
that's not even a joke how did we get
here two years ago I did a spotlight on
mecha mentioning its seeming decline in
popularity but ending it on a sort of
optimistic tone of mecha isn't exactly
relevant right now but maybe things like
darling and the Franks might save it
let's quickly refresh our memories about
how that one turned out
but now that the decade is almost over I
wanted to take a deeper dive into
looking at Mecca as a whole in the 2010s
and trying to get to the bottom of what
exactly happened to one of the most
iconic genres anime has produced and I
think a good place to start as any is
the most iconic franchise in this iconic
genre for as long as I can remember
Gundam has been the flagship mecha
franchise responsible for many people's
introduction to mecha and it actually
had a fantastic showing this decade
between unicorn and Thunderbolts and the
origin we had some of the best the
franchises ever had to offer for fans of
the universal century timeline then
potentially the most impactful Gundam
series has been the build fighters and
build diverse spin-off when I assume
some guy bands I was looking at model
kits and was like hey what if we made
beyblade but with Gunpla and then
someone was like does that technically
count as mecha and he was like who the
[ __ ] cares it's gonna sell a [ __ ] ton a
Gunpla and then they sold a [ __ ] ton a
Gunpla but the pattern you may notice
here is that while they were all great
shows for Gundam fans you actually have
to be a Gundam fan though unicorn and
Thunderbolts can technically be watched
by newcomers they were OVA set in the
Gundam timeline with a lineage that
spans all the way back to 1979 which
isn't exactly the most newbie friendly
and to gain hype there needed to be a
show that appealed to both newbies and
veterans there was an attempt with
Gundam space Africa I mean I'm blooded
orphans being one of the more accessible
series Gundam has ever had but for
whatever reason it just didn't take off
which leads me to honestly think that
maybe Gundam as a franchise is just too
vast and intimidating for newcomers now
no matter how many reboots new timelines
or spin-offs they add so that begs the
question is there any other beloved
mecha franchise that could have taken up
this mantle probably the biggest
franchise was Code Geass sporting a
spinoff OVA in certain resurrection film
I'll get back to that later
Haruka 7 had a sequel every erecta 7 fan
pretends doesn't exist Full Metal Panic
also got a sequel thirteen years too
late for any fan to actually remember
what was going on and yeah I think
that's about everything
meanwhile in Macross land
[Applause]
so that leaves all the new and original
IPS that came out this decade and to
give you a good idea of the sample of
what we had to choose from here are the
most popular mecha shows of the 2010
according to mal in ascending order SSSs
grit man robotics notes lights of
Cydonia undefeated Bahamut Chronicle Ava
3.0 sousei no gargantia out no zero
infinite stratos darling in the Franks
and at number one guilty crown yes the
most popular mecha show of the last
decade was guilty crown and that's
barely even a mecha show but even
ignoring that if there's an immediate
pattern to be seen here is that a fair
few of these had a lot of hype and buzz
around them and were actually delivering
all they needed to do was to cross the
finish line and competent fashion ah oh
great they just broke the [ __ ] ankle
guilty crown was the first real one to
get that ball rolling and was
immediately a huge hit the moment it was
released it looked incredible with some
gorgeous character designs and
interesting world some of the best
animation production i.g had to offer
and still has one of my favorite
soundtracks of all time this was my
introduction to Hiroyuki Sawa nose work
which I feel is only appropriate because
it definitely had a sour note worthy
drop in quality when after about halfway
through the series the protagonist
decided it was time for his scene phase
and the series just kind of went next up
on the list of shop till you Sawa no
drop the ball came out of Noah's zero
this show had so much potential and
probably way too much hype and
anticipation on the build-up we had a
brand new studio in troika coming out
with an original IP mecca series that
was backed by names like general Buchi
and Phase II Rose al key that started on
an absolute bombshell that blew everyone
away especially this guy this was going
to be the firetruck that put out the
dumpster fire Guilty Crown had left on
the mecha genre and we were all right
and of course most recently there was
not in body body daddy daddy
and well you already know how the story
goes
what's all three had in common was this
trend of setting up this really
interesting world and premise in the
first half only two completely [ __ ] the
bed with batshit plot twists and
absolutely awful character writing to
derail the success of the series and
hamper any possibility they had to be
taken seriously but here's the thing
guilty crown odd no zero and darling in
the Franks are all kind of guilty
pleasure shows for me because looking
back I still ended up enjoying all of
them but not for the reasons I really
wanted there was a time I was genuinely
invested in all three of these shows and
had really high hopes they could turn
into something great and then after I
got over the initial anger and
disappointment that every single one of
them had taken a turn beyond saving I
just switched off my brain and enjoyed
the experience of watching how big of a
train wreck they could become and the
resulting shitstorm they caused and that
kind of sums up my enjoyment of Mecca
this decade it hasn't been one of or an
amazement
it's the same kind of enjoyment you get
from watching the trashiest reality TV
show about people who every week finds
new and original ways to [ __ ] up their
lives in a way you thought could never
top the previous week something
encapsulated by every new franchise
studio sunrise tried to make being the
mecca studio the biggest original
sunrise Mecca this decade was probably
valvrave The Liberator which basically
felt like sunrise looked at code geass
thoughts what if we just take all the
ridiculous plot twist from cozy arts and
they could show about that and then they
did resulting in his glorious dumpster
fire you thought it's gonna get more
stupid or ridiculous with each passing
episode until we just proved you wrong
which i think is perfectly encapsulated
by this one comment that says I don't
think we'll be seeing sex in an anime
like this and then literally one Episode
later out of nowhere a character just
gets full-blown goblins layered
predictably it did stir up some
controversy so a year or so later
sunrise was like you know what we can
fix this I have a better idea
so the looked at valvrave thought what
if we just take this one rape scene from
valvrave and then make a show about that
and they did and it was called cross
Ange
Shadowman
however I don't really want to give the
impression that wasn't any good Mecca
shows his decade though because there
was a slide from Gundam Unicorn and
thunderbolt which I've already mentioned
Code Geass kita the exiled was [ __ ]
brilliant arguably the most visually
interesting and exhilarating action
series mecha has ever seen this could
have been so much bigger if it just
didn't air as an OVA series over four
years released with an inconsistent pace
as for standalone TV series there were a
handful it just felt like they all came
with an asterisk mixing them sousei no
gargantia was a solid gainer of Bucci
written show but as mecha Elliman was
limited to essentially just chamber who
was often more an actual character than
a war machine star driver was a gorgeous
looking show with giant thick robot hips
but it was very divisive some people
absolutely loved it but I feel that got
a similar amount of hate at that time as
well if I had to pick a favorite
original mecha this decade it would
probably have to be grid man which had
elements of the over-the-top
hype super robot shows that in my
opinion was some of triggers best work
but I feel that would be cheating a bit
because it's so deeply rooted in the
tokusatsu genre so saying this is my
favorite mecha show of the decade would
be a bit like saying my favorite
transformer series is Power Rangers but
I don't really have any other choice
because everything else was just okay
and that's kind of the story of the
decade
every good mecha show seems to up inside
to an OVA or pre-existent franchise
known on mecha fan girl their way to
find or are shows that don't really feel
traditionally mecha which is also where
our ad or the mecha harems or mecha
Musume shows because i feel the purpose
of a mecha show isn't to make you
actually want to [ __ ] the giant robots
right right so what does this all mean
for this iconic genre in the future well
to be short I have no [ __ ] clue
looking for the only new big development
I see is the literal resurrection of a
ten-year-old franchise and Code Geass
with plans to continue it for another 10
more years I've yet to see it but I've
actually heard a lot of positive things
about the Lelouch of the resurrection
movie but even so as much as I love Code
Geass and the original cast I'm not sure
I want 10 more years of coke Geass or at
least I don't think I want 10 more years
of Lelouch the only way I can really see
this franchise working as if it goes
down the Gundam route well you have new
stories that take place in the same
universe further down the timeline with
a completely new cast that can explore
entirely new thing
and maybe have the old cast appear here
and there as cameos or supporting roles
because if you're gonna resurrect the
olds beloved cast to have them carry the
franchise for the future its plays into
the exact same problem that has plagued
this genre in this previous decade you
are just appealing to pre-existing fans
rather than making new ones there's
gonna be more grid man more Patlabor
more Knights of Cydonia but that doesn't
really mean much
I'm sure mecha especially Gundam has
still had a super profitable decade and
selling drones and drones of model kits
but that was never really the problem
here the most glaring issue about the
last 10 years is that I feel there
wasn't really any show that was gonna
convert people into mecha fans while
mecha was by no means all bad it was
something that was hard to appreciate if
you weren't already a mecha fan which is
why in today's fandom within the vast
pool of anime fans that exist nowadays
in all variety of tastes if someone
tells me they're hardcore into mecha my
gut reaction is just ha all can be mine
because as a mecha fan or you can really
do right now is look to the Past mecha
might be a genre with a huge history one
so rich that most mecha fans will always
have something great from the past that
can pick up even if there's nothing to
look ahead to but without those shows in
the future to capture new fans all we'll
be doing is looking back while it might
be easy to say that every hype show just
didn't deliver or Gundam just doesn't
have the same puller used to or CG
ruined mecha I'm afraid that they might
just be the simple case that traditional
make of stories just aren't as appealing
in this day and age but that doesn't
mean it needs to be I feel like the
genre is waiting for something like that
breath of the wild moment without one
show to reinvent it into something more
relevant and really changed the
perception of how a mecha can be viewed
for modern audiences something it had
always been able to achieve before I
normally try to end these videos on the
hopeful notes but at this current point
there isn't much I can grasp onto when
looking towards the future I'm not even
that big of a mecha fan and yet even I
feel there's been a glaring hole that's
been missing in modern anime and
unfortunately only time will tell if
there will be a future for the iconic
giant robots
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to Ella
for Robert our Borg
basil Vulcan and everyone else my patron
for helping to support me from this
month and making this video possible so
I've got a small thing to discuss with
you guys today and that is I'm not sure
if I'm gonna be making an anime in 2019
this year or at the very least it's
going to be late I know I know that's
probably disappointing to hear but I do
have my reasons firstly is I kind of
just want a Christmas holiday this year
this is my seventh year in a row doing
it and I think I've just hit my limit of
working from the moment I wake up to the
moment I go to sleep every day except
for Christmas so I kind of just want to
relax a bit this year second is I've
always seen this video series as a big
celebration of everything that happened
in the previous year and it's
unfortunate that I just didn't watch as
many anime as I wanted to this year so
it's gonna take me a lot of time to
catch up and right now I don't know if I
have the energy to put all this effort
to a massive projects that I know is
gonna take me a lot of time for
something I Reno is going to be late
rather than putting my energy into
something next year so still unsure if
I'm gonna make one this year at the very
least I'll do a best of 2019 or whatever
I choose this series has always been
like my babies my passion project
because it's never been monetized it's
always copyrighted claimed because I use
copyrighted music so I never make a
single dime off of it I'm just really
proud of my work with the series so
unless it's going to be the best they
can be I'm just not gonna make it and
I'll just take here to reset and I'll do
one next year
see ya that's just an update on my
progress hope you guys understand and
you'll find out what the result is by
the time my next upload goes up so until
then I'll just wish you a Happy New Year
now I hope you had a wonderful Christmas
and I'll see you guys next time